great grand chaps joining us sadly i
can't be with you this morning because
i'm quarantining having come back from
the united states
what i've come to your work mr shaps
well this is quite a complicated thing
to put in place k
essentially you've got to match up the
medical ability that the science as it
were
with the number of days with the
capacity that is or isn't available we
all know
um how difficult it's been despite
having the biggest uh amount of testing
available anywhere
in europe um in the uk we still wanted
to make sure we could you know make sure
tests were available for doctors nurses
teachers
and many others before turning to uh
people traveling uh from abroad and
we've done that by
turning to the private sector for these
tests uh and
there are more complexities as well
you've got to make sure you know who's
taken the test and what the results been
and feed that back into
the passenger locator forms there's been
a lot of things to work out to get us to
this point
but i think now what we've got is a
system that other countries
will indeed follow yeah i mean the head
of uh heathrow airport one of the
busiest airports in the world or
certainly used to be
i said back in july that quarantine was
the way forward what's taking you so
long
well we've had quarantine all the time i
i i guess you must have said testing was
the way forward
um but the reality was indeed so slip of
the tongue let me
um in fact i what i wanted to ask you
further was how many jobs it might have
cost
yeah well what i was going to say is
we've seen other countries try to put
things in place at france and germany
and elsewhere but actually for example
they had testing on arrival
but actually later discovered that that
wasn't picking up
the coveted cases so you had a situation
where a test on the day of arrival was
only picking up seven percent of
cases and that's obviously no good it
doesn't protect the domestic population
who hasn't been
i haven't been away and everyone's been
working so hard to drive down this
virus we didn't want to jeopardize any
of that it's taken some time
to get the science and the
administration and
the technical side of this all together
what we've got
and announcing today is a system that
will allow people as you say rather than
to have to quarantine or self-isolate
for 14 days
to do that uh with a test on day five
and then as soon as you have a negative
result you'll be able to
then leave quarantine or self-isolation
which will be
i think a boost to the the travel
industry and obviously enable people to
travel more yeah
i'm not sure that you've still clarified
why it's taking so long to do well let
me let me explain a little bit more
detail richard you you've chat
it's a good it's a good challenge okay
let me just i've asked you three times
i've asked you three times and you've
not answered my question so well let me
let me i didn't want to bore you i
didn't want to bore your your listeners
but let me explain in which case um
they're not at all they're always
honestly here let me move on
let me okay let me just explain one of
the small technicalities how would you
decide
you've challenged me that i haven't
expected oh will you decide
why have you not i've asked you three
times go on okay well look
one of the things you'll know about when
you travel from abroad is there's a new
passenger locator form
one of the things that that form needs
to do is know where you're staying
and then there's the technicality of
needing to update that if you do get a
successful
negative test so that for example uh
public health england and the police
don't then calm and pursue you for
having left your home so you've got to
tie that
in with medical evidence about how do we
know that day five is the right day to
go rather than
day one or day seven or day eight and
all of those things have taken
a lot of time and energy and work to
calculate and work out i'm afraid the
science has taken time
along with the administration along with
the private sector
being able to be at capacity to deliver
the kind of private testing that will
now be
enabled so all of those things have had
to come together and i hope you accept
there's quite a lot to do there
which is why it's taken this amount of
time
i wish we had an hour to chat but we
don't how will you decide which tiers
are
implemented around england well we've
got new data coming out
uh in the next day or so which is why
the actual
uh specification of which tier goes into
which place
uh will take place on thursday and it
will be on the basis of
a number of cases for example a number
of cases in the over 60s where
it's much more likely more possible that
it could be
fatal and things like the speed at which
coronavirus is rising or falling in a
particular area
and a couple other measures along those
lines so we'll just look at all the data
for the country and then we'll be able
to allocate the tiers out
to the country as a whole didn't work
last time that's why we had to go into
lockdown why should it work this time
well we it is it is the case we want to
have these tears just a little bit
tougher than before it is very important
that
people follow obviously what the tears
say and that the tears are capable in
themselves of bringing the levels down
so we will be going back to some things
that are familiar to people that the old
rule of six for example
but we'll also be making sure that in
some respect these tiers are a little
bit tougher because
it's important that having now we hope
as we come out
on the second got the r8 back we hope
below one we wait to see that data that
we're able to continue to hold and drive
it down
uh further what happens if regional
mayors disagree is there an appeals
procedure
well what we're going to do this time is
actually allocate these across the
country based on the scientific data so
rather than getting into individual
negotiations in different areas which
i'm afraid rather delayed the uh the the
start of um some of the tiering
uh last time and i'm afraid that in
itself was one of the reasons that
it led to perhaps not getting on top of
it as quickly as possible
instead we will have a regionalized but
national approach where we just look at
the data
and say on the basis of this data that's
why this particular area will go into
tier one two or three
so just to be clear it's andy burnham's
fault
i'm not blaming anybody but i mean it's
clear that in liverpool uh
where tier three came in quite quickly
we've seen the cases come right down
it's been a real success story
we have seen elsewhere where tears
didn't come in
as quickly for various different reasons
that actually it wasn't as successful
and that is
a fact i'm afraid and we don't want to
be in that position again
which regions are you thinking of well
as i say
it's important to follow the data so we
will have a look
what uh the latest data says i think
it's published tomorrow
and then thursday we'll be able to put
the entire country into one of
uh three tiers yeah but you're not
answering my question again
are you saying it was andy burnham's
fault um no i'm not i'm not saying it's
anybody's fault but it is a fact
that we saw uh come on well
look i don't want to personalize it like
that is what i'd say but it is a fact
that areas that were slower to
go into particular those tier 3 levels
have not seen did not see the time the
cases reduced areas that went in
earlier liverpool is the obvious example
have
seen cases fall and that's very
important in terms of protecting the nhs
and
protecting lives i mean i i you know
it's simply to
stay state the the obvious in many ways
some people might say he was trying to
stand up for his uh
region i'm sure he'll try and do that
again last week i think the most
important thing if you're standing up
for your region is to save people's
lives yeah i think that's probably what
he was trying to do
last week data showed that supermarkets
were the most common place
visited getting a positive corona virus
test why is retail
being opened across all of the tiers and
yet pubs and hospitality
will not be well one things we know is
that
people need to be able to go about their
lives and supermarkets is an obvious
example where people need to
be able to pick up food and and goods to
go about those
their lives it is you know
not very enjoyable but of course
possible to
go about your life without visiting the
pub and so we have had to make
choices i'm afraid that's been the case
all the way through this
education is another very obvious
example it is a choice that we want to
keep
kids in school that we want to be able
to keep universities open
and though some things have to come for
others in this overall
effort and i think the good news is as
we sit here today
that we are at least in a situation
where there's some better news coming
over the horizon with
the mass testing that we've seen being
so successful
in the vaccines but in the meantime i'm
afraid we are going to have to put up
with
some continued restrictions and perhaps
as we go through and into
next year and then see the cavalry of
vaccines and
mass testing coming over the horizon
yeah so the hospitality um industry is a
sacrificial lamb and that's all there is
to it at this stage
some people know in in in tiers one uh
it will remain open and in fact it will
boon there because it will
not be a strict 10 o'clock closing as it
was before
and 10 o'clock would be last orders
people will be able to carry on till 11.
there's a little loosening there in in
the second and third tiers though
it does get progressively tighter and
third tiers uh can only open with their
selling food for uh takeaway or delivery
or drive through in fact
um but i mean you're absolutely right i
mean they have suffered terribly we've
tried to bring in a lot of support and
not only the
twenty five thousand pound grants at the
beginning of this but also
up to three thousand pounds a month now
uh to help pay for for example
the rates builds uh and of course the
furlough scheme that's been extended
through
uh but no one is pretending any of this
has been
easy okay it clearly hasn't been and we
will just we're all fed up with it and
we want to be
out of the other side um but you know as
a country i think
we've worked together unbelievably well
to try to
see the back of this coronavirus and i
think there is an end at least
in sight but for the time being really
important that we carry on
following these restrictions when the
new tears come in
aim into that 22 billion pounds for
tests and
uh tracing apparently is what it's going
to cost
i'm just looking at a report from
warwick university
saying that there was a technical error
on the 3rd of october at least 15
841 people who tested positive for covid
um had not been contacted by the test
and trace
system and they um analysis
as a result of their algorithm says that
that resulted in 125
000 additional infections and more than
1500 deaths
this is what you need to get right this
pesky test and trace
well i think we've said that we want
test and trace to be a lot better and
and
think that you know clearly there have
been issues
with it having said that uh millions of
people have been contacted who otherwise
would have been
walking around and of course the test
and trace system relies
itself on and people providing accurate
information contact numbers and
those types of things and where we do
have that information 80 percent of
people are
uh being contacted so look you're right
it it it ain't perfect
we want to make it better that happens
when we all contribute towards the
system
do what we're asked to do by nhs test
and trace if we're asked to self-isolate
but also provide contact information to
nhs test and trace
but i should say actually there are now
155 areas
where there's local test and trace in
place with another 100 local authorities
uh having applied for that status as
well
so a lot of this is now taking place
place
on a local basis and i think that's a
good thing they tend to know their areas
better and maybe people
will also respond better when it's with
a local connection
okay but how much more money is it going
to cost i mean it's cost 22 billion
pounds that's
more than the channel tunnel cost even
if you
convert it to what it would cost today
money and also cross rail
so how much money do you need to get it
right yeah i think that includes 7
billion
sort of going forward as well that's
just been announced
look the truth of the matter is that
coronavirus has cost this country
a huge amount it's cost the world a huge
amount and we've always said we will
have to do whatever it takes to get
through and beyond coronavirus nhs test
and trace is a very important part of
that
has many different elements as you know
that the app has now been downloaded 20
million
times as the latest figure that's
helping to protect people
nhs tests and trades the contact tracing
people following the rules
all of these things come together uh to
try to
to help but i mean to answer your
question um directly
you know we have to get through this
korean virus and i'm afraid
uh there has been no other option but to
spend a lot of money over 200 billion
pounds on all of the support and other
things
related to supporting the nhs and much
more besides but
uh you know we're starting to see with
money for example invested in
vaccine and vaccine research okay that
that money has been
in many ways very well spent as regards
getting us out of this thing
final question before i let you go you
were chair of the conservatives at a
time when
bullying amongst activists was said to
be rife it cost you your job you weren't
immediately involved but you were the
chairman and you uh you took the hit
you must feel a grave sense of injustice
that the home secretary is still imposed
well just to be clear actually the
bullying you refer to referred to took
place six months after i was chairman it
wasn't whilst i was
there i just wasn't really happy with
the way that it was being dealt with by
the party
at the time and decided that i thought
it was the the decent and proper
uh thing to do as it had been an
appointment that i've made when i was
um chairman but look i think you're
you're referring to
um pretty patel who's given a reserve
apology
uh if uh her actions which as the report
says
uh there were times where she wasn't
being properly supported in her role
as well but nonetheless she's apologized
and i think that was the right thing for
her to
say and do and i i think that moves the
matter on
so you support her i do i think she's a
very good
home secretary she's a very determined
person in the
job and and i know that she wasn't
always getting the
support that she should have done and
that she wasn't made aware of some of
these
issues as well and she's apologized
for where her behavior may have caused
problems so i do think that draws a line
in fact